- So Ben and I were just
walking around Rite Aid
and found Reese's Crunchy Cookie!
Which I have never seen,
apparently they came out
like mid-May of this year?
- Yeah.
- But it's new to both of us.
- Never seen it before,
super excited, cookies and Reese's?
The best things in the world!
(upbeat music)
- What is it?
Crunchy cookie?
- I'm honestly kind of
tearing up! (laughs)
- Can we eat it?
- I feel like this is a trick.
- This just smells like glory.
(exclaims) I'm sorry!
The chocolate came off
and I saw the inside.
- Ah.
- I think my mouth is already watering.
Give it to me. (laughs)
- You've gotta bite it at the same time.
- Oh my God.
(brass music)
- Oh my God! (laughter)
- Mm. Oh my God, I love it.
Some mad genius thought of this.
I don't know if I can go
back to regular Reese's.
- Look at the tiny chocolate chips!
It's everything Reese's was missing,
but you never knew you needed.
- Dude. The crunch changes everything.
It tastes like cookie dough.
- I love everything about this.
- Thank you, Reese's.
Send some more to the BuzzFeed office.
- Please! (laughter)
- You've outdone yourself, Reese's.
- I think I don't like when people mess
with a good thing, but like.
- That was so good.
I'm really sad that it's over.
This is gonna be the new standard
for my Reese's consumption, like,
I don't think I could go back.
- Final thoughts: Keep
killin' the game, girl.